tous à cheval une quinzième de montures
autant de cavaliers pour ce spectacle
estival dirigé par katia creuser mais
par quatre on garde les deux trotteurs à
l'extérieur et puis en mai les deux
petits à l'intérieur ces répétitions
organisait régulièrement permettent de
réviser les classiques
ici par exemple le pape espagnol et
avance oui bien oui très bien voilà il
faut qu'il décompose data faut pas
qu'ils aillent vite
même si chacun sait ce qu'il a à faire
il est toujours intéressant et important
de faire et refaire les exercices et
c'est bien revient encore un petit coup
à l'épaule oui c'est très bien il ya
toujours quelque chose à faire il ya
toujours quelques choses à rectifier les
chevaux ont acquis les ordres qu'on leur
a enseigné mais il faut toujours les
entraîner pour qu'ils les fassent mieux
ça c'est bien faire mieux pour réussir à
embarquer le spectateur dans un univers
extraordinaire
il faut faire plaisir aux autres qu'il
faut donner l'envié aux autres
spectateurs et les étoiles dans les yeux
là les gens qui comme ça dit qu une
gitane implora la lune jusqu'au moment
de détente entre deux séances de travail
obligatoire pour que les étoiles bris
longtemps dans les yeux de chacun
tu ne trouves pas l'amour qui exauce ta
prière
dis-moi lune d'argent
toi qui n'as pas comment c'est envoûtant
je vous avoue que nous on a chanté ça
tout l'après-midi après mais je crois
que c'est fait exprès le l'envoûtement
comme ça c'est un petit peu la magie du
spectacle en plus avec avec le feu faut
savoir que normalement sallèles le
spectacle se joue plutôt de nuit inquiet
je parle avec katia qu'avec la grande
chef d'orchestre de tout ça c'est
c'était un spectacle qui normalement se
fait de nuit donc cette chanson on la
chante tous et je crois que c'est fait
exprès c'est fait exprès on a en a même
des spectateurs qu'on l'entend
chantonner en sortant et c'est vrai
qu'avec l'aspect nocturne d'avoir cette
chanteuse ses éventails de feu fin c'est
quelque chose d'assez assez sublime
vraiment quand est-ce qu'il a germé en
fait dans l'esprit parce que ça fait un
petit bouton que quelques cas un cabaret
proposé c'est ça faisait un petit bout
tant que ça trottait dans la tête
commence comment on met ça en place que
ce n'est pas facile malgré tout alors
comme tout comme toute pièce qu'on
compose cdi décès après les rencontres
avec des cavaliers avec des artistes des
chanteuses des chanteurs des danseurs et
savoir un peu qui on va faire cohabiter
avec qui et ce que chacun peut apporter
de son univers et voilà des fois c'est
un peu dur à mettre en place parce que
il des idées qui sont pas toujours
réalisable mais voilà c'est super mais
après c'est ce qu'on disait en fait
chaque spectacle est différent parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de comédiens qui
viennent et des comédiens différents qui
font pas forcément tous la même chose
c'est ça oui oui alors on est un petit
noyau dur mais on a toujours
des artistes qui viennent qui vont qui
viennent en fonction de leur date de
leur disponibilité et de leur art donc
on pose chaque année avec du personnel
différent
et alors comment ça se passe en fait les
spectateurs qui viennent ça se passe
derrière mon nom c'est vraiment tout ce
qui se passe ici d'ailleurs il ya plein
de choses qui se passent derrière nous
il ya des visiteurs en fait les gens
s'installent tout autour comment ça se
passe quelqu'un qui vient voir le
spectacle cabaret alors quelqu'un qui
vient s'installera donc dans la longueur
du paddock les cds table des tables avec
des places assises et il ya une
restauration sur place et l'avantagé
c'est que c'est la formule cabaret où
l'on peut manger pendant tout le
spectacle est vraiment on peut on peut
profiter d'un moment qui est assez
magique dès le moment où la nuit tombe
parce que l'on travaille avec du led
avec du feu avec de la lumière des
éclairages donc c'est très très joli
alors là il ya plein de choses en fait
qui se passe ici il faut le savoir qui a
déjà creusé elles forment aussi d'aider
des personnes à la sécurité équestre est
en fait c'est assez multitâche si on
peut dire mais comme ça va pas commencer
à dire est en fait vous préparez aussi
un challenge avec les chaînages internet
et canal chiens et chevaux peuvent
travailler ensemble c'est on part dans
un autre registre mais vous avez
vraiment un éventail assez large quoi
oui alors on doit se diversifier donc si
on veut travailler et vivre
on doit se diversifier dans le milieu du
cheval et les collaborations qu'on a eue
avec la police donc police municipale
gendarmerie nous ont amenés à créer ce
challenge inter unités et caisse sur les
conseils de thierry demaegdt alès et
c'était court no une première est de
mettre en avant la collaboration avec
l'animal avec le cheval c'est quelque
chose de parfaitement complémentaire du
monde cynophile et c'est aussi
formidable avoir parce que on utilise
les qualités premières d'un cheval qui
sont le courage la coopération et la
gentillesse donc ça marche très bien en
fait dans le budget pour la pour l'autre
c'est que les gens et les autres
travaillent ensemble animal et humain
donc là en fait il est prêt parce que
sinon il reste trois dates trois dates
lesquels les cas là le 23 le 24 et le 25
août donc deux soirées
et vendredis et samedis soirs à 20h30 et
puis un dimanche après-midi pour les
personnes qui souhaitent venir en après
midi qui ont pas envie de conduire le
soir on a fait une représentation à
16h45
vous avez entendu donc regarder on est
tous les trois tous les quatre pardon
pardon j'oubliais effet on vous attends
attends on est prêt